how do I get sin is the Institute of
arson ideas unique festival combining
days full of talks and debates in
philosophy politics arts and science
with evenings full of music and dance
get your tickets for the world's largest
music and philosophy festival but how do
I get in double gratitude has now been
studied by positive psychologists and
some of you are probably aware of the
positive psychology movement it's been
going for what 20 or 30 years and this
is a movement among psychologists who
are trying to find out what makes people
happy what makes it a radical departure
from traditional psychologists that most
of it was about what makes people
miserable because psychotherapists after
all mostly see people who are miserable
and so there's a lot of studies on what
makes people miserable
but the positive psychology movement set
out to find out why up here what makes
people happy they started with a series
of studies in which people had beepers
which went off at random times and they
had to write down what they were doing
and what how happy they felt on a one to
nine scale and it turned out that people
throughout the day their level of
happiness varied of course but the
activities they were involved in when
they were happy were very varied
sometimes when they really absorbed in
their work
sometimes when they having a great
conversation sometimes they knew making
love sometimes when they're dancing or
singing sometimes when they're playing
games the common thing with all these
was that they were in a state of flow
and that's what made them feel happy
what made them feel unhappy was boredom
disconnection separation isolation
disconnection from what's happening as
part of this study one of the things
that turned out to be related to
happiness was gratitude it turned out
that people who are happy are very often
very grateful people so the skeptics
said well of course they're grateful
they're grateful because they're happy
so they wanted to find out whether it
was well they're grateful because
they're happy or are they happy because
they're grateful so they did experiments
be
scientists to find out and and they did
some simple straightforward experiments
they divided groups of people into three
samples at random one lot of people
wrote down all the things that had made
them miserable in the previous week
another lot just wrote down a story from
the previous week and the third group
the gratitude group wrote down what it
made them feel happy and what they felt
grateful for in the previous week and
the people who were recalled things that
had made them happy for which they felt
grateful were measurably happier four
days afterwards the exercise that made
the biggest difference to them was what
they called the gratitude letter where
they asked him to think of someone who'd
helped them in their life who they'd
never properly acknowledged sometimes a
teacher sometimes a family member
write a letter expressing their
gratitude and then go to that person and
read the letter to them and when they
did that these people that were much
happier for at least two months
afterwards so what they showed is that
gratitude is a very simple practice it's
present in every single religious
tradition giving thanks for what we have
and all the blessings in our lives and
in a sense it's obvious that it's
something that people have always done
and it puts you in a flow because if
you're grateful you acknowledge what's
come to you that you give thanks it
continues the flow the opposite of
gratitude is a sense of entitlement or
taking things for granted and it turns
out that people who are grateful a much
more popular with others than people who
take things for granted feel entitled
and complain all the time well that's
not very surprising either but these are
findings of positive psychology in a
sense reinforce the obvious but in the
modern world unless things have the
imprimatur of science the seal of
scientific approval out people don't
take them so seriously
get your tickets for the world's largest
music and philosophy festival at how the
light gets in aaaggghhh